last week we talked about the
establishment reaction to president
Trump's European trip and pointed out
all the I why eyes pompously
pontificating about it remember that
black swan author Nassim Taleb z'
brilliant phrase to describe elitist
groupthink intellectual yet idiot I why
I I said there'd be a lot more after
Helsinki and I wasn't wrong this is part
two but like others even on this network
I was upset by the Russia summit this is
personal for me my parents are Hungarian
they escaped Eastern Europe but for most
of my life the rest of my family lived
under communism
I hate all authoritarian communist
dictators and that's what Vladimir Putin
is so president Trump's treatment of him
in public look the president would
probably consider an insult like I would
to be called an intellectual but that
press conference was definitely idiotic
here's what I said on Monday the
president totally wrong not to strongly
condemn Russia attack just wish
establishment type like Senator John
McCain were as fired up over the regime
that attacks us more than Russia is more
brutal authoritarian than Russia is a
much bigger threat than Russia Xi
Jinping's China but as happen so often
these days the hysterical over-the-top
reactions of the angry hate filled
conspiracy mongering elite or even worse
yes the I why eyes were out in force led
by their severely creepy John Brennan
well good on Dan coats to stand up for
women and men of the intelligence
community and those who are going to be
silent in this administration are
complicit and so they need to be able to
speak out very strongly but what mr.
Trump did yesterday was to betray the
women men of the FBI the CIA NSA and
others and to betray the American public
and that's why I used the term that this
is nothing short of treasonous because
it is a betrayal of the nation he is
giving aid and comfort to the enemy
and it needs to stop treason idiot and
we saw escalating idiocy all week with
Democrats suggesting that President
Trump is literally a Russian agent
his senator Tammy Duckworth Republicans
in Congress cannot continue to turn a
blind eye towards the very real
possibility that Vladimir Putin has
compromised our commander in chief and
turned him perhaps without his knowledge
into a Russian asset and here today was
the divisive 2020 presidential wannabe
Democratic congressman Seth Moulton do
you think it's possible that the
president is a Russian asset with or
without his knowledge well I'm just
saying that I don't know as usual
the extremism of the left pushes people
not away from President Trump but
towards him look after all the unhinged
Russia talk this week there are two
important things to remember first that
Putin is not the only nor is he the most
dangerous communist dictator threatening
America
China's Xi Jingping is much more
authoritarian much more evil and a much
bigger threat China has been meddling in
our democracy for years and you've
barely heard a peep out of the elites in
Washington mainly because they've been
corrupted by Chinese cash as we will
show you in a can't-miss swamp watch
next Sunday the second important thing
to remember is that we are the ones
who've made our democratic process
vulnerable to foreign attack by buying
into the idea that technology improves
it here's another iyi in action this
week rod Rosenstein talking about how
the Justice Department is planning to
protect the 2018 midterm elections
public attribution of foreign influence
campaigns can help to counter and
mitigate the harm caused by foreign
sponsored misinformation when people are
aware of the true sponsor they can make
better informed decisions we also helped
technology companies to counter covert
foreign influence efforts the FBI works
with partners in the intelligence
community to identify foreign agents as
they establish their digital
infrastructure and as they develop their
online presence what an idiot
dear Deputy Attorney General the more we
rely on big centralized technology the
more fragile and vulnerable we are if
you want to make our elections secure go
back to people marking their ballots
with a pencil and paper
human beings counting them in school
and phoning in the results on a landline
I'd like to see Vladimir Putin or Xi
Jingping try to hack millions of pencils
across America but no our intellectual
yet idiot ruling class has been bribed
and mesmerised by big business and big
tech what a bunch of idiots tell me what
you think at next Rev FNC and at Steve
Hilton X and make sure you pre-order my
new book positive populism here's the
website you can get it positive populism
dot Oh